our planet is home to a puzzle involving
chiral molecules these molecules come in
two varieties both made up of the same
atoms and bonds and even though they are
mirror images they don't exactly match
it's like trying to put a right-handed
glove onto your left hand
life on earth is made up of groups of
chiral molecules that share just one
handedness this is called homo chirality
for example the amino acids that make up
the proteins and our bodies are all
left-handed without any bias one way or
the other chemical reactions will make
equal amounts of left and right-handed
molecules but in order to make a group
of homo chiral molecules the bias must
already be there to begin with so the
source of the homo chirality in
biological systems the see of this
chiral bias is one of the deepest
mysteries in chemistry researchers think
the solution might lie in the balance of
chiral molecules in gas clouds in the
interstellar medium that's the matter
that exists between the stars in our
galaxy scientists think that at one
point the balance must have tipped in
favor of one handedness over another but
a chiral molecule has never been
observed in space until now recently
scientists aimed radio telescopes deep
near the center of our Milky Way galaxy
at an interstellar cloud Sagittarius b2
sure enough they detected radio waves
that bear the fingerprints of the chiral
molecule propylene oxide this discovery
is the first step in seeing if chirality
in space can explain homo chirality on
since it's thought that interstellar
clouds contained the raw ingredients for
the formation of our solar system
studying the chiral molecules inside
them may even shed light on the origins
of life itself the next step is for
scientists to determine if the propylene
oxide molecules they've detected are
mostly righties or lefties